ya t ou griezmann le frère d'antoine
griezmann qui avec nous il ya ton frère
qui nous a laissé une petite vidéo
regarde bonsoir c'est antoine griezmann
une petite vidéo pour mon frérot théo
est si c'est pas non ça lui sert il
bonsoir tpm paix au public aux
chroniqueurs voilà une petite vidéo pour
dire mon frère que je suis très fier de
lui
très fier de ce qui fait sa demande
énormément de travail remercier baptiste
pour l'avoir aidé dans sa nouvelle
colas plein de bonheur plein de réussite
et
s'il est là
déjà un pied un petit trou dans mon
calendrier entre sélections et et club
je viendrai sur le plateau pour faire
une petite d'arc a donc voilà ma bientôt
et allez les bleus
[Applaudissements]